When you're
in Memphis, you got to do the ducks
If they sell, you definitely
have to come up and see the ceremony.
It is an experience unlike any other.
It's like the Ducks owned the hotel
The Duck March ceremony is exclusive
to the Peabody Hotel
in Memphis, Tennessee.
There was General Manager back in 1933
that went on a duck hunting trip
with a friend of his over in Arkansas.
As a practical joke,
they decided to bring back the live
duck decoys that they were using
and set them loose inside.
That found some of the general manager
woke back up the next morning
in the clear mind set.
I'm sure he probably got up with his life
when he got down here.
There was a crowd of people
standing around the fountain
staring at these dogs
that led to ducks living in the fountain.
But then seven years later, a man
by the name of Edward Pembroke
just so happened
that he was an animal trainer
in the Ringling Brothers and Barnum
and Bailey Circus as a young man.
And he was the one that came up
with the idea
of turning the ducks,
living in the fountain into a ceremony
I have
the honor and the pleasure
of marching the ducks for you
all this morning.
My title here at the Peabody
Hotel is of the Duck Master,
a very unusual title.
The whole is my job to train
the team of ducks that we have here.
And they have a $200,000
duck palace upstairs on the rooftop.
Hey, good morning, Doug. Good morning.
I hope everybody gets a good sleep.
It's nighttime out.
Is it going to be a great one?
A lot of people.
It came a long way to see you all
This is a public ceremony,
and it happens twice a day. Every day.
One at 11:00 and one at 5 p.m.
there would be in least
two to 300 people on the busy days.
The number of people doing the duck
march. We're talking into the thousands
Ladies and
gentlemen, if I
may direct your attention
to the elevators,
having just left their penthouse
on the roof to join you.
Looking good.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the march of the world
famous Peabody Ducks
all the way to the fountain.
I need everybody to use the steps.
Come on, Douglas. Let's do it.
Everybody say good morning.
Duffy's and
bad
and everybody use those steps for me.
Everybody up the steps.
Looking good.
There's one, two, three, four and five.
Great.
Doggie
I have never seen anything like
the Peabody ducks around me
ever before in my life.
We certainly do not have this
in Australia yet.
With something
I'm probably never going to forget.
Ever.
I'm now a duck.
I'm a duck fan.
To know you're providing
an experience
that's unlike any other is a privilege.
Yeah, I don't consider it a job.
I feel like it's
no pun intended, but it's a calling